okay just introduce myself a little bit
I'm a Java Champion I have one of the
most uh answers in the world on stack
Overflow for Java and the jbm I was the
first to get a gold badge holder in
memory filo and concurrency in any
language
on stack Overflow so
my most recent article got about 17 000
views uh in in a couple of days and some
of the content here is based on that
article and also previous articles
um
what else
okay so as an organization
um we a lot of our clients are in
banking but a lot of our open source
software is used all over the world so
we get about 7
000 downloads a month from different IP
addresses for our individual open source
software and overall it's about 4
million a month
across all of our products but in terms
of commercially 80 of our Revenue comes
from tier one Banks
one of them you probably know is a UOB
for example it's a local bank
so today I'm talking about
um a number of topics that have really
got my interest and attention recently
um something I see again and again
between different clients
um and one one of the things that
frustrates me the most is the level of
uh what's called accidental complexity
an accidental complexity is where
um uh your application is spending a lot
of time doing things that are not
actually business requirements or even
requirements from it either
and certainly we've seen cases even
quite recently where it's two or even
three orders of magnitude of the time
spent is not actually
fulfilling the business need but is
actually just because of the tools
although it's strategy they've used or
the approach they've taken so I look at
a specific example that's covered in one
of my articles
another one the one that got the most
interest is about
showing that allocations don't scale so
as you as you have more and more threads
creating objects you reach a saturation
Point such that the system cannot
allocate more objects just by having
more threads and this is shared globally
so if you've got multiple virtual
machines then it's not partitioned it's
not a shared Resource One four CPU
virtual machine is enough to saturate an
entire server almost regardless of how
many CPUs it has
uh so um so it is something that you do
need to pay more attention to than you
probably may have done in the past
um then I look at both Behavior driven
development and data-driven tests and
why they are relevant to low latency
systems in particular or also makes
systems more maintainable and improves
the velocity of development and then I
could go into some coding examples so
all of these have got benchmarks and
code the Articles have links to them
from my blog but I'll show you some of
the code here today as well to give you
an idea of what does this look like and
if we have time we'll get into some
durability guarantees and why they're
important to look at in particular if
you're you have a database in your
critical path that can be such a
dominant feature in your latency and
choosing determining your throughput
that nothing else you do probably
matters too much so
look at some alternative strategies for
not using the database in your critical
path
so what we want to do is we want to
focus on clear requirements that either
come from the business or from I.T or
we've established ourselves and stick to
those requirements and say well what's
the most effective way of delivering on
them rather than what what's something
that works
and that that discrepancy can be
enormous
and in particular I've so many projects
we see particularly in banking but in I
guess also in other other Industries
where the velocity of development
declines quite rapidly
to the point where it's very hard to
change anything compared to when the
project started and what we want to do
is avoid that happening so if we we saw
we from the start make sure that that
the velocity of development can be
maintained then you have a much more
maintainable project you can keep
delivering to the market new changes all
the time and your project won't
essentially be put in uh put put it to
one side and say well we can't develop
this anymore it's just too hard let's
start again
so accidental complexity is is uh where
your application is spending time or
resources on things that aren't actually
a requirement
and in particular this can also be when
developers are spending time on things
which are not the business doesn't
actually require and that's often down
to not having clear specifications
um where the business either can't tell
you or hasn't tell you or it's not been
communicated or maybe it's convened
communicated to someone else but not
necessarily to you and so going back and
focusing on what does the business
actually need what does it actually need
from you because the business won't
specify all their requirements
um
uh and uh really focusing on that you
can cut down the amount of work your
team has to do cut down the amount of
work the application has to do and
deliver much faster
uh whereas this sorry essential
complexity is that what you actually
need to do what can't be taken away
maybe you can do it a little bit
differently but fundamentally your
application will need to do that because
that actually meets a requirement
now how is it possible that you could
get an accidental complexity that large
right like two or three orders of
magnitude one of the causes of this is
um your application will have multiple
levels of abstraction right and even in
our case we try and cut down the number
of levels of abstraction but still there
are multiple levels of extraction each
level of abstraction won't will often do
a bit more perhaps even a lot more than
is really required by your application
at that time and by the time you've run
this through multiple levels each one of
them adding a percentage they multiply
together until eventually you can get 10
times 100 times and in some cases even a
thousand times
more effort going into it than what is
actually strictly required
foreign
concrete example right so I'm just
throwing numbers out to you at this
point but so in this case this is a
benchmark where a message is sent via a
queue to a service or a microservice and
that microservice sends back a reply
which is in fact the same message back
again via another queue and they're
picked up by the client now look at the
round trip latency now Kafka is a is
described as a low latency product it is
lower latency than a lot of Alternatives
it's not a bad implementation that's not
what I'm suggesting here and in fact
when I benchmarked it I was able to get
latencies around half what the a lot of
the vendors that support it publish so
it could I think they can actually do
better if they improve their benchmarks
they would get better numbers but
um yeah so so I can still get good
results with Kafka but doing exactly the
same thing with a Chronicle queue and
this is the open source version
um the latency difference is around
about a factor of 750 to do the same
thing right send a message serialize it
deserialize it persist it
um all this is all on one machine so
it's a very simple configuration
simplest possible configuration so
Network traffic isn't really part of the
equation here we're just looking at the
overhead of passing a message to a
service via a queue and getting it
backfire a cube
so this difference is so large that it
can be difficult to even conceptualize
and part of the reason why it's not such
an obvious problem is that in this
Benchmark Kafka was getting on the 99th
percentile which is the worst one in 100
Cafe is getting about four uh 2.6
milliseconds now in their own benchmarks
they're getting about five milliseconds
so I thought it was being reasonably
fair to them by actually getting 2.6
milliseconds so how far can the signal
go in in 2.6 milliseconds so instead of
representing it in terms of an amount of
time you can't even imagine you can't
see 2.6 milliseconds let's turn it into
a distance like how far can the signal
go in that time so that's something you
could think of considering as well is
that if you're trying to convince
someone this is a a long time but it's
still you're working on a system where
actually this is shorter than you can
see how do you convey that
another way and um so 2.6 milliseconds
is uh about the time it takes to send a
signal from Singapore to well past Kuala
Lumpur so that's quite a long distance
that a signal can go in that time
whereas with Chronicle the uh the amount
of time is uh it's around uh 30
microseconds and the distance that a
signal can go there is from Boat Key to
Clark key so you can see that's a much
shorter distance
and like I said it's doing the same it's
meeting the same requirement
right
and it's even difficult to chart so this
is a log chart where on the vertical
axis you've got powers of 10. it's the
only way to get them both on the chart
at the same time because the difference
is enormous as you can see like on the
90th percentile you're getting around
three microseconds here up there you're
getting about 2
396 microseconds and that's at a lower
throughput if you increase the
throughput too similar to what I was
doing for chronicle
it goes up by another factor of 10 or
even 100.
so it's quite a huge discrepancy and
again like I said this is just doing the
same work and I'm not necessarily
talking about messaging here we've seen
other examples where
uh doing the same function but in a
different manner can cut down by one two
or even three orders of magnitude
so what's the benefit of doing this
right so what I mean
things this is this is
um uh so what how does this help me as a
developer right because the business has
said oh they're happy with a few
milliseconds and
um actually there might be what is the
benefit to having it less than a few
milliseconds right because you're
meeting the business requirement well in
this case what happened in this uh this
is uh how long it takes to build our um
one of one of our key pieces of software
is the EFX trading system
and uh it's time to compile all the code
run all the tests now each of those
tests starts up a service and shuts it
down so instead we're not timing how
long to send a message just how long to
start up a service
test it and shut it down again and check
that it's doing the right thing so in
this case it's doing 466 tests it's
doing the Java dock building at creating
the jar and everything even though end
to end uh it takes 77 seconds to do the
whole lot on my development machine so
this is just on one machine test the
whole thing including some integration
tests
and um
and and and one of the key points is
this is only if you're doing everything
right obviously if you're just in some
point tests with one microservice for a
key piece of functionality you're
talking about less than a second and the
benefit to you is that that means your
whole development life cycle is much
much shorter because you can run through
hundreds or even a thousand tests in a
very short time frame because everything
is running very efficiently and very
fast and it can run on your local
machine without having to go you know
push the software up to some server wait
for it to upgrade
um and then maybe you run into some
issue because you're using a server that
someone else is using and you've got
some sort of conflict going on none of
that's happening here because your your
system is efficient and fast enough that
it can just run on a single machine
so that's that's a benefit to you right
it's just it helps you be more
productive not just it runs faster in
production
uh
yes there you go that'll do
uh so moving on to the next topic so
this is about
um this is something I've seen again and
again
uh not so much in our space because in
low latency space you tend not to create
a lot of objects
a lot of it for this reason
um so there is a perception that uh
creating objects is cheap and the truth
is
if you've got one thread and you run a
jmh test and you're creating objects
they are cheap
but in production you're not running one
thread you're not just using one core
you run it you want to use all the cores
and if you want to use all the cores
they're all accessing they're all going
through a small number maybe only one L3
cache they're all sharing that L3 cache
and that's a contended resource so
really what you want to do is each one
of your threads you want it to fit
comfortably in your L1 and L2 caches and
even though you can now get gigabytes
and even terabytes of memory in a server
your L2 cache is 256k that's for code
and data
so the last thing I want to be doing is
creating memory pressure by literally
filling it with garbage
right as fast as you can
so so an example I've got here
the time it spends uh pausing is uh I
compared to the time it spends doing
allocations is a factor of 80. so the
the the cost of allocating is 80 times
higher than the cost of actually pausing
itself so so tuning the pause reduces
Jitter and show that shows up in your
metrics it's something you record but
the cost of allocating can be much much
higher
and even a small number of allocations
can make a big difference
at least to a benchmark and it and it
won't necessarily affect your
application but what it will do is it'll
affect your ability to handle High load
or bursts of activity
so this is a again uh the sources in my
blog for this but
um if you've got just two in this case
I've got two threads creating small
objects of uh 44 bytes as fast as
possible how fast can two threads create
44 byte objects and you get a pretty
good rate of um
126 million a second
that's a pretty big number and the
allocation time is very low 15
nanoseconds and generally if it's just
15 nanistics you wouldn't need to worry
about it right however by the time you
got to just four threads and this is a
machine that 32 logical threads
um by the time you got to four threads
it's starting to tick up right it's not
getting twice the throughput anymore and
in fact the average latency has gone up
by 20 it's now 18 nanoseconds but still
18 nanoseconds there's nothing to worry
about it's not going to make a big
difference however you see that
initially as you add more threads the
throughput doesn't go up really the six
seems to be slightly better but
essentially 32 even across two jvms you
get the same allocation rate as you did
with four threads so all those
additional threads weren't really being
utilized or they weren't adding any
benefit because in somewhat
unrealistically I'm creating objects as
fast as I can
and and importantly
um in this case uh the average latency
has gone up from 15 nanoseconds to 150
nanoseconds it's ticking 10 times longer
to do the same thing because I've
saturated the box and it may not be used
actually in the Box it could be another
virtual CPU running on the same physical
machine saturating the L3 cache of the
memory bus is actually the one that's
caused the problem here
if we move on
so I've got a slightly more realistic
test where we were sending message
events over network connections over TCP
again it's all on one machine to keep it
simple it's going over loop back but in
this case I'm sending events as fast as
possible Overlook back similar to the
previous scenario I'm sending an event
to uh nfco service and it its only job
is to send that event back again right
now to keep things sufficient because
we're in a low latency space we're not
creating any objects to do this all the
serialization deserialization the lookup
the method calls all none of that and
the proxies none of them are creating
any objects whatsoever
but then you might say well uh why why
do that why go to all that effort of
creating no objects what what difference
would just one object make right so
you've got a lot of applications out
there that if you told them to handle a
whole request you can only create one
object they probably think you're crazy
right but even one object does make can
make a difference so
so in the middle chart I'm looking at
how many events per second can this
system process if it's not creating any
objects whatsoever and I looked at
different jbms different GCS and
parameters and the GC doesn't matter too
much because the bottleneck
here is the on the on the left hand side
is the ability for the kernel to
basically push data around over a
loopback
and the average latencies are very low
but you can see that they're so low that
our 150 nanoseconds although in this
Benchmark it's more like 170 nanoseconds
really makes a big difference
right so so in this case what the
Benchmark does is if you run it in a
certain mode it will create one object
for every event instead of creating no
objects for every event and that one
object for every event has reduced my
throughput by 25 already that's a 44
byte object not a big one
really so it's just that one object has
has really cut me cut down my throughput
you still get very good throughputs but
obviously as you add more and more
objects it's just going to go down
further and further in terms of what
kind of throughput my system can sustain
um one thing that's interesting here is
there is an uptick from java 8 to Jabra
11.
but otherwise the version doesn't seem
to make for this use case at least
didn't really make a lot of difference
Java 17 happened to get the slightly
better result
I'm not sure that if you had a different
use case that would that would also
happen but anyway
so if we go on
so so what I mean without going to all
of this work and trying to Benchmark is
there something simple I can do to work
out whether it's likely to be a problem
or not
um and in fact the the peak throughput
um at which sorry allocation rate at
which
um your system saturates doesn't
actually vary that much between servers
to be honest
um so my high-end laptop which has a
battery life of an hour and something
but it goes very fast
um it Peaks out at about eight gigabytes
a second a typical server will pick peek
out about 10 gigabytes a second which is
a nice round number and uh the ryzen I
was testing on before was peaking only
about 12 gigabytes a second
and I tried this on a number of
different machines and the actually the
variation between them really isn't that
much and a figure that um uh Cliff click
quoted for a very similar point is that
he he quoted around 10 gigabytes as well
as as a good rule of thumb so so from
your perspective all you need to do is
look at all the allocations of all the
jvms on your machine I totaled them up
and as a percentage of 10 gigabytes
that's how much of the time the system
is spending allocating objects as a
proportion of the time it's doing so if
it's creating a one gigabyte a second
total then roughly 10 of your CPU is
that it's being used goes towards
allocating
which is quite High really and it's much
higher than your GC time probably you
might find that if you added up the GC
time so in The Benchmark previously
um it slowed down the throughput by 25
but the amount of time spent in GC was
0.3 percent
it's very low
very efficient you'd look at that 3.3
and say well allocations aren't a
problem for me geez garbage isn't a
problem for me because it's only 0.3
it's not making any difference but
actually that's not the biggest problem
the biggest problem is the fact that
you're creating memory pressure and then
hitting a contented resource
so yeah my earlier point that actually
and some systems actually two CPUs is
closer is enough to saturate the machine
but on a good server it um even four is
enough to saturate it and adding more
numer regions and more sockets doesn't
necessarily help very much I mean it
will help but it doesn't help it doesn't
scale right you have two sockets in data
one
um this idea was about 25 more
throughput could be achieved with two
than could it be achieved with one
foreign so moving on to the next topic
so
behavior-driven development is one of
the best practice techniques for
ensuring that you are extracting
requirements from the business that are
clear and something you're doing up
front and making sure that before you
even start ideally you have at least
some high level requirements that
they're looking for and this is a a
methodology for doing this now this
isn't just an exercise for the business
this actually will help you in writing
although latency or efficient software
because what you will do is allow you to
focus on what are the things that you
actually need to do like end to end not
all the things going on in between
um I don't know how many times people
have told me that it was a requirement
to do something that I know for a fact
if they tried to explain it to their
business what they're doing they would
have no idea what they're doing or why
you think about well you think this is a
requirement go and ask the business if
they even understand what you're doing
let alone
uh with is that something they would
come to you and say uh this field should
be an integer and not a long right
and then you'd have to explain to what
what is the difference and why do I care
and how much money will that make me
right and you go
you know so
so this this will help you focus at
least on the requirements they can give
you that doesn't mean all all
requirements come from the business in
reality uh it will have their own
requirements you will know from
experience there are things they are
going to need which they don't even know
they need yet
um so you some of the requirements will
come from your own experience or your
team or your security team for example
they will have their own requirements
which is just the way they do things
um don't necessarily want to question
you just say all right that's what
they're looking for that's what we would
deliver
but once you've even got all of those
you you find that um focusing on just
those things and not
um getting too much into the detail too
early can help you deliver just the
minimum that system needs to do
so uh so the the overall phase here is
that you start with um some some way of
detailing at a high level their
requirements you create scenarios that
fail so this is a test driven
development and then you create an
implementation that fixes that and this
isn't always the the approach you need
to take but vast majority this isn't
done enough
um in so many projects
um
and then you have a passing scenario and
one of the key steps here is refactoring
so that's about reducing technical debt
reducing technical debt might not seem
important to the business and this is
one of the things that you might need to
explain to them is that reducing
technical debt will allow you to help
maintain velocity as the product matures
as it gets more complicated it will
become progressively harder and harder
to maintain if you're not paying off
this technical debt reducing all of the
issues the things that okay yes it works
but it does it in such a horrible way
that it's going to be really hard to
maintain later so you want to have at
least some of the time and effort spent
making sure that the the code is clean
the implementations are clean that it
all makes sense that it's all that's not
just lots of things bolted together
um and um that will help them in the
long run particularly if you're a
developer and you work on the you get
into production it's all the
um a lot of successful projects will
cost three times as much to run in their
life than they did to create in the
first place
so
um in making it maintainable helps
reduce that long-term cost
so one of the benefits of behavior
driven development is as I said you can
focus on people who have the domain
knowledge either in the business or the
I.T side and they can help you give the
requirements the problem is that they're
not always accessible and sometimes when
you get stuck getting into the minutia
and the real detail that you still you
need to write a real program
they're not always interested or have
the time to go through it in absolutely
every piece of detail
so right it's a rough rule of thumb is
that say for a large project you want to
be able to have about a thousand tests
or a thousand different scenarios or
whatever
um in general the business will be able
to give you like 10 off the top of their
head before we've even started right
just in the first conversation it will
just come out these are 10 things top 10
things I need
right but then over time you may do
extract out more and more details and
feedback but you might only get to about
a hundred
right
but then you've got this Gap right
there's a still enormous gap between
what they can tell you and what you will
probably need to really nail down the
system and make it maintainable now what
you can also do is if you've got domain
expertise and you've got requirements
from it you can go through the same
exercise you will know 10 things off the
top of your head like Dr or
monitorability all these things that
they may take for granted that are just
there
you can you can you will probably go
through a similar exercise there'll be
10 things off the top of your head and
over time you'll get an about another
100 things that you know need doing they
don't need to tell you to do that but
you still there's still an enormous Gap
and we'll get into how you can bridge
that one way you can bridge that Gap
um so because we're dealing with real
time in our case real time low latency
we model all of our Key Systems on event
driven architecture which is
um events in and events out and in
between you have a function that
function is to entirely dependent on all
the events it's ever seen
and that way it's completely
deterministic that that engine will
process those events the same way every
single time
and in that case we record every event
as well so you can take all the events
from production for example put it on a
development PC and either fix bugs or
run it again and again to improve
performance you know try out different
performance approaches
um
you move on okay so in this case
um the ones in green are cues
um and uh the ones in the boxes in the
middle are the functions that are just
purely dependent these are sometimes
called Lambda functions more technically
they're Kappa functions which is they uh
just event driven systems and on the
outsides we we tend to
um like when you're interacting with the
outside world and other systems we have
gateways their job is just to normalize
the data from whatever you're connecting
to to your internal data model
so they're usually stateless and so
they're usually one once you build a
stateless system and all it does is
transform usually becomes quite stable
it only has to change when the protocol
changes or your internal data model
changes a lot of the really interesting
stuff the business logic is in
um like control systems in the middle
they
uh
they have to maintain some sort of State
in the sense that
how they act will depend on previous
messages so for example if you want to
cancel an order you you that will depend
on whether what the order was right so
that will be a previous event
so the way to still treat this as a
function is that it's a function of
every event it's ever seen so every
input comes in as an event every piece
of reference data every piece of
configuration it gets told absolutely
everything gets pushed to it right it
and if it does need to go away and get
some additional information it spits out
a message and the output that is read by
some other system that will pick up that
information then feed it into its input
so now if you want to test this or
reproduce its state for a failover for a
debugging all you need is the inbound
messages in this case and the software
for the control system and you can
recreate its state at any point
for debugging for example and checking
you've fixed it you don't need any of
the rest you don't access to production
databases any kind of production systems
you don't need to run any of the other
components because when you're just
recreating it they don't need to be
running
uh that means you've got a nice
self-contained testing framework and it
makes it then very easy to develop that
microservice in isolation
so one of the key benefits of this
approach is it makes it very easy to
create regression tests so a regression
test isn't so much saying for this input
I expect to get that output which would
be nice that that's what that would be
the goal that would be the 100 you got
from the business and the 100 you got
from it
but um sometimes that that detail isn't
available to you
so instead what you can do is create
regression tests so you say for this
input which I know is a scenario that
will happen or might happen or I need to
consider could happen
what does it actually produce
and I can look at what it actually
produces and it's up to me or the team
to decide well how much do we check that
you can either make it as a pure
regression test where you don't even
look at it and then the benefit of that
is that if something changes in the
future you will at least know that it
changes you will at least know that it's
produced a different output now than it
used to do which one is correct
you haven't really spent enough time
investigating but you at least know when
something changes
um obviously if you can spend some time
saying does this look sensible if you
can show it to the business and say does
this look sensible does this look right
um then that would be great but that
doesn't always happen in reality but you
don't need it to you can still generate
a significant number of regression tests
and at least have some stability and be
at least aware when things change
perhaps unexpectedly because you know
one of the big risks of any change is
unintended consequences that you're just
not aware of and this at least will help
you cover those
foreign
regression tests are very simple you you
take a series of inputs and I did often
you would just take a series of inputs
that are valid and have already come up
previously so you don't need to create
them from scratch
and then you just play with them you
change uh make invalid inputs you put
duplicates in you drop out messages that
should be there and just see what the
system does
and you can record those results and
then check whether that behavior ever
changes in the future
[Music]
uh and this can be used in realistic
cases
um so in this case we've got a series of
cues which are in blue in between a
series of services so the same queue can
go to multiple Services the pricer in
this case takes data from multiple
inputs and all of this can be canned and
produced into tests or and regression
tests and they can be used to get the
two techniques can be used together
um so one of the areas that we differ
and again I'm still talking about Open
Source Products here is that we Advocate
using a high level interface which is a
Java interface with pojos that's it
we're not talking about fly weights over
off heat memory or anything really super
low level that can be very hard to work
with right we're talking about being
able to still do low latency coding but
still have something that looks like you
know most Java developers would expect
um so these are some sample interfaces
that the top one is a really simple one
that I use in some of my examples
um you've got one event that one event
is modeled as a single method call which
takes one argument which is a piece of
text
in a slightly more realistic example
um we've got an interfer interpret to an
OMS an order management system you can
you can send in new New Order singles
you can ask to cancel a request and in
each case it takes a dto and that dto
has all the information associated with
it so the order manager has an input
interface which are all the events that
can come in and there's another
interface for all the events that can
come out and obviously you can use
things like inheritance and so on to
compose these it doesn't have to all be
flat
but going back to the simple example of
the say so you've got a Sim it's it's an
asynchronous it's a bit like
asynchronous RPC in that you don't wait
for the reply it's just an event you
sent but from a coding point of view
it's really simple you just you you're
making a method call you don't need to
know all the details there oh well
actually this is going to be serialized
and what serialized version format am I
going to use and is it going to go to a
queue or is it going to go over TCP
none of that is in the business logic
because that's not what the business
logic is about business logic is I have
this piece of information in I need to
do something with it and I need to
produce this piece of information out
how you actually do that as a transport
or whatever is really a business
requirement sometimes it is sometimes
they will know it needs to go over fix
or it has to go to this Kafka queue or
it has to go over here but often unless
that's a specified requirement you don't
need to be going through all of that in
your business logic
so the code to do that is really simple
so there's two key elements to here the
component expects to be given an
implementation of where is going to
write out all of the outputs so it's
just an implementation of the interface
in this case it's the one with one
method and then it has a method which is
where what gets called when that event
comes in
so in this case because it's all it does
is add an exclamation mark as you can
see when when an event comes in
to uh to this component it will produce
the same event going out with an
exclamation mark added
and as you can see this is not low level
coding right this is not bytes that
you're having to worry about this is not
about all Heap that you're having to
worry about or
um all of those factors because at this
point you're only interested in what is
this function supposed to do from the
business logic point of view in reality
all of this can go to off-heat cues and
be persisted to disk via memory map
files and then share over shared memory
but none of those details are important
to what you're trying to describe and
test at this level
um so the way we we our testing
framework works is you have yaml for
input and then yaml for the expected
output
the benefit of doing that and separating
the two is that the output can be
maintained very easily and so in the
trivial case with an ex regression test
you don't know what the output should be
you can just generate it right from
scratch
and in this case uh each each event is
modeled as a document in a field a field
of a document so that say in this case
is the field name but that's the event
name which is the method name they're
all just it's just a one-to-one match
um and the string that comes after it is
the string on the method call
um and and when you make those metacles
in a test harness it produces exactly
the same recorded as an output
why go through all of this effort well
the main benefit is that if you need to
maintain this so
um I mean there's lots of different ways
you can check whether you've got the
right result or not
but a lot of the time spent is if you
didn't get the right result why didn't
you get the right result right sometimes
in complex examples that's really hard
to find out and also sometimes that can
be really hard to fix right because you
okay I've worked out that it's this this
field has changed I've now got to go
into the code to figure out well what do
I change in this test and now make it
pass
and then you have to do this for every
test you've got so say you've got
several hundred tests that you have to
update this can be a really really
tedious exercise to go through every
test figure out what's changed what's
wrong
fix what's wrong and then go on to the
next test whereas if you use this
approach you could even run it in a mode
where it just does a regression test
you'll run all 600 tests it just
overwrites all the expected results and
instead what you do is you review it
when you check it in or you review it as
a PR because the and you don't have to
write you even touch the code to do it
that's the ideal case in reality it's
not always that simple because you may
find actually some of the changes
weren't intended they're not desirable
and you actually have to fix either the
test or the code
but let's let's see what happens if
there's a discrepancy
so you're probably familiar with seeing
this sort of thing for a unit test
failing
um it says click here to see the
difference and because it's doing a text
comparison the ID already has support
for this and it looks like that so you
can see in this case I change the input
ran the test again without changing the
the expected result
can anyone spot the discrepancy
as you can see it's pretty clear and if
I wanted and I just want to treat it as
a regression test I can now take the
actual result copy paste overwrite the
expected result and now the test passes
whether that's a good thing or not it's
down to your judgment you can see that
if that is the right thing to do it's
really easy to do right and that's even
if you're going to go through and do it
manually there is a mode where it will
just override it and do it for you
um let's look at a more realistic
example where it's more complicated
because as it gets more and more
complicated that's where the benefit of
this approach helps so
this is a new order single from the
previous interface so we've got a dto
now with a number of fields of different
types and one of the things you may
notice is that the symbol which is
actually text so it's an instrument
which is something like euro dollar or
IBM shares or whatever
um that could be implemented as a string
or possibly an enum but in this case
it's it's being encoded as a long and
all you have to do is add an annotation
that specifies how will I encode it to
text and vice versa you can come up your
own strategies but base 85 has the nice
effect that it uses the 85 most common
ASCII characters
and you can get 10 characters packed
into a an eight into a long so it could
be variable length string of up to take
10 characters of most of the ixq
characters you're likely to use and
still stick it in along if you do that
at a from a text level it that's not
going to really make a lot of difference
but from a binary level it makes a huge
difference because this creates no
objects right storages along it also
means that comparison is Trivial because
you're just comparing two Longs you're
not having to look into those objects
and then compare them you can also
validate them at this point as well you
can ensure if you're in your converter
you can validate whether it's about it's
correct or not that way you won't even
import something that's invalid right
from the start
um another one that's very useful is
encoding the timestamp so instead of
using say local date time which has
nanosecond resolution which is an object
quite a complex object and and quite a
bit of overhead again you can just use a
long which is the number of nanoseconds
since um 1970.
um and in a real example this is a real
real test
you can see that in yaml it's still
readable it's the text is the timestamps
appear as a timestamp the symbol appears
as a string but it's actually encoded
for you in in as a long in binary very
efficiently
you can still have strings you can still
have enums if you wish
but you have another option not to use
those if for efficiency reasons
so then what happens if I break the test
is it still easy to see what I broke
well you'd be the judge
can you see what I broke here
right can you also see if I just wanted
to take the expected result and make the
test pass but that would be really easy
right
because without even looking at the code
right you could fix this without needing
to understand well if that's the path
you're going to take if you decided
actually it shouldn't have done that and
you need to fix the code well obviously
you may have to go into the test or you
may have to go into the the original
code but
um in terms of your easy option it
couldn't be much simpler
and we have examples where we've got a
megabyte in and a megabyte out of data
and tracing through all of that is
really tedious if you break something
but using this technique it will scroll
down to the point and you'll see the
exact thing that's different
now in a slightly more realistic example
we do add a couple of things to to add
some functionality
so because we are interested in the
latency and these method names are quite
long from our point of view can actually
make a difference in a benchmark
um we you have the option to turn them
into numbers instead of being strings
and in fact we were looking at some
numbers today actually and the four
nines that's the worst one in ten
thousand can be reduced by
um a factor of two if you use some of
the lower level techniques this is one
of them there are other techniques you
can use but in combination can reduce
your your high percentile latencies uh
significantly but you don't have to do
this up front this is something you can
do later once you've got the system
running once it's all stable you can
play around with these annotations and
say well do they help or not and in fact
even the previous tests where I had a
string and a date time that's something
you can change later that yaml doesn't
have to change so once you've built all
the tests they they're not touched by
this
um it's only the implementation you're
you're playing with to optimize it
how are we going for time
I see him assume we're going for good
for time and I'll I'll just go through
this quickly
um it's one of the key things in any
project if you're if you're looking at
the end-to-end latency is is there going
to be a database uh in your critical
path and what are the the durability
guarantees you you need because you're
going to use a database that will
dominate and then it'll be about well
how can I use this database most
effectively
however there are other options that can
still give you good uh the data the
durability guarantees which is you know
how likely am I to lose data and how
much data might I lose
you can get other options without
um necessarily going down their Road and
that can significantly reduce the
latencies involved and then it then it
does matter how your how your
application runs
so if you started a database the sort of
typical latencies you might see are in
the order of 10 to 100 milliseconds this
is often enough in in certain
applications however using other options
you might be looking at 2 to 20
milliseconds 10 to 100 microseconds or
even 1 to 10 microseconds and obviously
in that case we tend to be more at the
bottom here
also sometimes looking at redundant
messaging as well
so in this scenario
um the sort of model is that you've got
some client or some Gateway or some
source of information
and you've got a server that's
processing that information what does
what needs to happen before you process
it or you before you send a reply does
it need to go to disk doesn't need to
have a redundant copy on another server
does it does it need to go to a file so
that if the application dies that's fine
um there are a number of different
options and they will make remarkably
big difference to how much latency that
operation takes
so
um in in this in the lowest latency
option the least guarantee is say you've
got an application and all you care
about is how long will it take to write
that message
not how long it will take to process or
persist it's just uh you've got an
application that's been logged or
monitored or for compliance purposes
it's being recorded and you just want to
um that all you care about is the right
time and this is one that's often
benchmarked because it's the lowest
number you will get right because it's
doing the least
so but it's something to watch out for
because if that's not your use case a
benchmark that shows you the public the
time to publish isn't going to be very
helpful because that's not what you're
looking at but if all you care about is
is recording or logging and that's a
very common use case then the time to
publish is the is the one that really
matters
um and as you can see there are options
out there and we're not the only ones
where there that that that delay is
extremely small and this is in
microseconds right so we're talking
about
um 117 nanoseconds typical latency here
it's extremely low
um however sending the same message but
using acknowledged replication so you're
sending a message to a server and then
getting a response back saying that the
second server has a copy that can be
still very quick so but we're bringing
that up to about 16 microseconds typical
and that'll be either
um on a there will be a say on a low
latency Network so two two machines
quite close to each other
um low latency infrastructure end to end
you can get it uh down to about 16
microseconds if you looked at something
like AWS you might be looking at 40 to
60 microseconds but still a very low
number still much lower than say writing
to disk for example uh much lower than
writing to a database
um and uh in the SEC the The Higher One
there is you have the option to give a
hint to the so so he's writing it to a
memory map file you can give a hint to
the operating system saying it would be
a good idea if you wrote this sometimes
very soon
so it's not really a guarantee as such
but it is a mythical you can take to
prioritize whatever that means to the
operating system writing that data to
disk so it does minimize uh how long the
delay is between writing it and then
actually going to disk
um and that that brings up the uptick a
little bit so what this is doing is it's
telling the our operating system it
should write it out to disk and it's
telling waiting for at least a copy uh
for on a second machine which is close
by
and this is actually a pretty good
combination uh it gives you quite a lot
of quite a lot of robustness but not
necessarily as you know it's not for all
use cases but you can see that it's
actually very low I mean I'm still under
40 microseconds at this point
and um that's that may not be a make a
really big difference also it's very
consistent right so the worst one in 100
it's about 72 microseconds
but moving on
um what happens if that's not the
guarantee that we need or this is not
the guarantee we use what could be
achieved
um so the high end here is usually this
is the highest requirement is that the
the the OS or at least the hardware
controller not necessarily the disk
itself but the hardware RAID controller
has replied that that data has been
written to disk
right and um with um Spinning Disk that
was pretty high and quite bad but uh
certainly a decent Enterprise SSD which
is what was being tested here you can
get that down to about seven
microseconds at seven milliseconds seven
thousand microseconds uh typical and uh
99 percentile of about just under 17
milliseconds
um and if that's enough for you then
that's the best guarantee you can pretty
much get anyway so
um uh that that's that's going to be
fine now you can add in acknowledge
replication but that's usually so much
faster adding acknowledged replication
won't make much difference uh at that
point it's only how how long does it
take to send a message and get a reply
so it's just down to your network speed
at this point so if you're a knowledge
replication is from Singapore to Hong
Kong that will be it's the length right
it's the speed of light to send a
message that fast that's your bottleneck
um
but oh sorry before you go
what if we can come up with something
that's a bit of a Best of Both Worlds
here right
um where say you're sending a heartbeat
does that really need to be committed to
disc maybe not if you're sending a very
small trade so for example
um in stocks Securities the size of the
trade can vary enormously so you can
have really small trades and then it'll
be a small number of really big trades
and so how do we make it that well
instead of paying the penalty on every
single event how about we only pay a
penalty on the ones that actually have a
key risk to the business the ones the
business really cares about and says
these are the ones we can't possibly
lose
so what I did here is look at what if
you took that strategy and again it's an
assumption because it totally depends on
your use case what if this only happened
10 times a second so every roughly every
100 milliseconds a message came in that
you couldn't possibly lose you couldn't
continue until it had been committed to
disk but every other message
um just just can just go as soon as it's
available so it still means that every
message before it has to be committed
when this happens that because you need
all of them but you're only doing this
periodically and as you might expect the
typical latency is improved
significantly because typically this
doesn't happen
right so you get the typical latency
which is similar to just doing
acknowledge replication
but then in your higher percentiles
they're going to be dominated by how
long it takes to commit to disk but even
they are improved not not hugely but
they're still improves somewhat compared
to just persisting absolutely everything
now another step you can take is use a
faster disk so this is not a disc that
this is a high-end usually used in
desktop disk
there's a number of vendors that do this
at the moment
however in the next couple of years
possibly by the time you have a project
that needs this and it goes through say
a bank or your organization as being an
approved disc
they may have these speeds as well right
so we're talking about where is the
market going and
um I certainly I mean this is something
you can't buy today but it may not be an
option for you yet but as you can see
the typical latency is still quite high
but it's down to 1.7 milliseconds at
this point which is is pretty good and
there's still a benefit from taking this
sort of hybrid approach where only when
there's a trade too big or a message too
important or there's too much
outstanding data do you actually commit
yes so I'll introduce Jerry Who's the um
the local Regional
um MD and also introduced Vatican who is
properly locally actually lives here so
um
yes
so they they they can help you out with
a bit more detail I'm I'm based in the
UK even though I'm from Melbourne
originally so
um are there any any questions ping me
on that yes
but if you've got any questions you're
uh willing to ask now go ahead
you can ask me or them
yes
yes
yeah L3 memory uh L3 cache memory
bandwidth is is the bottleneck it
doesn't seem to it's not entirely linear
with the memory speed either if you use
faster memory a memory that's twice as
fast rated is twice as fast you don't
quite get twice the allocation rate
though
it does help but that that's the
limiting factor there so um so that's
why adding more CPUs doesn't really it
does help to a point
but that that point to which it helps
sort of maxes out a two three or four
CPUs and then after that adding more
CPUs just means uh they're more they're
waiting for each other more when you for
the allocations to go through yes
pretty much yes
uh yes so there's um core complexes this
one actually had that CPU I was testing
has to its AMD it has two core complexes
um so it actually has multiple tiers and
I did test that
um there's very little difference
between having say 16 threads running on
the single core complex or 16 threads
running across two cool complexes
is split across two core Composites it
didn't didn't really make a lot of
difference so it may be something lower
level than the L3 but
um that's that's roughly where I would
place it as being the bottlene
studies software to stop here sorry
yes
um well yeah if you run the cloud you
will still run into the same
restrictions at the hardware because
fundamentally they all Run for the most
part around AMD or Intel
and you'll and they tend to copy each
other's architecture in terms of CPUs so
you'll get a you should get a very easy
I would expect to get a very similar
result there'll be some saturation point
and it will be much lower than you might
expect in terms of the number of CPUs
required to achieve it
um uh between them that that's the main
takeaway
uh
yeah I I haven't in our experience as
you add more sockets you get bigger and
bigger machines
accessing memory generally gets lower
not faster like you get more CPU
but your memory bandwidth actually tends
to go down
because you've got a more complex
structure and
newer regions to worry about and so on
in terms of accessing that memory
actually takes longer
yes
and you consider that maybe in some
synthesis
um
yes certainly in our use case we don't
consider them at all
um because they do create too many
objects however
um
so often in our core systems we will
will try and make this very low GC but
then they need to talk to systems that
aren't as stringent requirements so they
may create a lot of objects that may be
using spring boot they may be using
JBoss for web servicing they may be
using um not all the systems have to be
designed this way but what we tend to
Advocate partly for this reason is that
you'll put that on a separate machine
separate physical machine and then
you're kind of isolating the problem to
that machine
so then um yeah it's fine to use all of
that and then you you at least won't be
impacting the critical path the critical
uh processes
and I guess there's there's garbage when
you start up and there's garbage in the
city state so um we've got lots of
customers who use spring to set up their
system
and then uh you know after a few minutes
after it started there's no more garbage
there might be some spring properties
floating around so you'll be very
careful of them but if you can avoid
them then you can kick off a GC 30
seconds in or whatever and you should be
running fine yeah and it doesn't have to
be absolutely zero garbage it just needs
to be so low that it doesn't matter
and that might be that might be
surprised still surprisingly high in
terms of raw numbers so a common example
and this goes back many years I've done
this many times is if you've got a
system that's creating say a gigabyte an
hour of garbage
which if they're 100 byte objects they
might that's like 10 million objects an
hour per jvm so you can have multiple
jvms doing this as well but there you
can have it under a gigabyte an hour
then that's 24 gig a day
right so you're still creating objects
still creating some garbage here and
there but it's just not very high level
and then you you can start your system
up with an Eden space of 24 gig
so you can just watch that Eden slowly
fill up over the day
and then you can run um and I've
actually done this do it as a timed
maintenance task to do a full GC
overnight
so once a day you do one GC that's it
and then the as long as you keep it say
within certainly with if you can keep it
in within the Eden space size
then there are no more collections this
just becomes not an issue anymore
and I'll tell you a gigabyte an hour
even going back to my estimate here
you're looking at far less than a like a
0.1 percent of the time is it's chewed
up by allocations
yes yes
yeah I I that that's partly why we
emphasize that it's not just about
making the applications efficient it's
also about making developers efficient
and often the cost of developers is more
than the cost of the hardware
right and sorry
yeah and um I mean the thing is if you
could halve your build time
how much more productive were you and
the rest of the team be for example
yeah
that's right and if you could reduce it
by a factor of 10
you would probably enjoy your day more
right for example you know it's it's not
just you'd be more productive it'd be
more enjoyable
so
um so we because when you do builds you
and you've got an established system
you're actually talking about having to
do quite a lot
many times many variations uh quite
often and um you're
um you would just like all of that to be
much quicker
foreign
thank you very much for listening